Pôle Emploi veut jouer la transparence
visite des locaux de l'agence de
Guyancourt ouverte depuis août 2012
particularité on reçoit les demandeurs
d'emploi non cadres et cadres une
vitrine pour l'institution publique le
taux de chômage atteint ici 5,5%
similaire à l'Allemagne en 2012 l'agence
lui en courtoise a récolté 5400 offres
essentiellement on a le secteur du
commerce avec le centre commercial
notamment 50 ans en Yvelines le service
à la personne bien sûr et tout ce qui
est je dirais
informatique
c'est les trois secteurs ont recrute
essentiellement une agence de Guyancourt
donc montrée en exemple 60 agents ils
sont affectés pourtant les
problématiques de retour à l'emploi sont
les mêmes que partout pour trois types
de population les jeunes les seniors et
les chômeurs de longue durée et les
chiffres qui viennent d'être publiés ce
matin-là pour le département ne sont pas
bons accroissement du nombre de
demandeurs d'emploi dans les Yvelines
une hausse plus rapide qu'au niveau
national plus 2,3% contre
1,4%, une dégradation de l'emploi
intérimaire qui enregistre sur un an une
baisse de 19,6% dans les Yvelines contre
12% pour l'Île-de-France ça reflète
plutôt une situation de marché de
l'emploi et plutôt moins dynamique qu'il
ne l'a été
et donc la conséquence pour les non
emploi c'est effectivement on a une
croissance de la demande d'emploi des
langues de longue durée on a aussi un
point de préoccupation pour lequel on
est parti mobiliser notamment avec la
mise en place des emplois d'avenir sur
la population jeune notamment les jeunes
non qualifiés qui sont partis en toucher
pour la des durées d'accès au premier
emploi ou des situations de précarité
qui sont des points sur lesquels on est
parti en attentif et on est parti avec
les équipes les Yvelines restent
toutefois un département encore épargnés
avec un taux global de chômage qui
s'élève à 7% à comparer au 10,5% au plan
national le département dans sa partie
nord en vallée de Seine souffre
notamment de baisse d'emploi dans
l'industrie automobile